les amis ce soir c'est le début d'une
nouvelle ère pour la droite
[Applaudissements]
les militants les élus qui se sont
mobilisés pour cette élection allait
plaire et pour son succès était bien
l'un d'eux d'autres aux attentes
vous avez envie et d'un visage sans
ambiguïté oui ce soir nous pouvons dire
là brad et le retour l'étions diviser et
nous n'avions messieurs est dangereux et
vous tournez images nous avons pour
reconstruire nous allons tous renouvelé
avec des nouveaux visages et surtout
nous allons tirer les leçons de nos
échecs
c'est une droite renouvelée qui solaire
aujourd'hui une droite qui assume ses
mains une branche sereine qui ne se
cachera plus dans les petit prononçant
laissera france elle sera déterminée
elles sont à droite
je veux dire mon respect pour ma défense
le nom sous droit de se présenter et la
politique a besoin de son qui défendent
leurs idées et je vous demande les à
venir
je me suis mis aux personnalités qui
n'ont pas voulu s'engager dans cette
campagne que je respecte leur choix
je crois au rassemblent au ce qui se
joue maintenant des passes dans des 100
personnes il faut reconstruire la droite
ils ont du talent et d'aujourd'hui quand
on a du talent il faut mettre au service
la trentaine il verse 1
[Applaudissements]
j'ai conscience des défis qui nous avons
le vieux message politique c'est des
vrais et bien entendu tant mieux parce
que nous allons tout réinventer
tant mieux parce que je suis convaincu
que les valeurs de la droite reste les
valeurs d'une majorité de français
le travail la liberté la transmission le
respecte l'autorité et l'amour de la
france
ils ont ce sentiment combattu la france
a besoin de la droite pour dire qu'on ne
peut continuer à tout donner aux classes
moyennes sont bien là
oui je suis convaincu que la france a
besoin de la droite ont refusé que
fautes d'économies son gaspillage de
l'argent public
le gouvernement ponctionne arrive à
cergy les familles et aux retraités
oui c'est qu'on attend que la france a
besoin de la droite parce qu'aujourd'hui
le président la république et passive
sur les questions de délinquance parce
qu'il est complaisant sur le
communautarisme
parce qu'il manque de fermeté face à
ravel raison
et je suis convaincu que les français
attendent une autre voie alors où
s'achève cette campagne nous sommes au
début d'une renaissance
il faudra de la détermination il courage
le courage de dire et le courage de le
faire et nous aurons les deux nous
allons faire renaître un espoir à droite
nous allons écrire une renaissance et
c'est la renaissance de notre relation
que nous proposons aux français vivait
république et vive
[Applaudissements]